this new study that liberal women in
particular
are going completely bananas uh we've
got a quote here from evie magazine
there was a new study and this study
which examined white liberals moderates
and conservatives both male and female
found that conservatives were far less
likely to be diagnosed
with mental health issues than those who
identified
as either liberal so we've got this
image up and this is
pew research okay these people are
reputable as far as i'm concerned
uh what you're seeing all the way on the
left there the 56.3 that's the the high
blue bar
that's white liberal women 56.3
of white liberal women have had a doctor
or other health care
provider told them that they have a
mental health condition
now you go to the right over there and
the 27.3
see white conservatives so this is white
liberals white moderates and white
conservatives
only 27.3 of white conservatives
have had this happen to them and what's
interesting so basically in effect
double so basically double
white women who are liberal are
suffering from some sort of mental
condition that conservatives are not
and i think you can directly link that
to the previous story
that if you only read liberal media you
don't know what is true anymore and you
can take any position depending on what
trump said
or you find out three weeks later that
every story that they tell you is a lie
you can't talk about
uh covet leaking from a lab then you can
you're told brett kavanaugh's a racist
then you're told he's not jesse smallett
was lynched then he wasn't lynched the
covington kids
were evil white supremacists then it
turns out that they weren't
trump tried to pressure the attorney
general in georgia to flip the election
results then if that turns out to be
false
these people are are inundating
themselves with nonsensical information
that doesn't comport with the real world
in front of them and then they're
starting to go crazy
because then they find out real
information but they're so tied into a
sort of political identity
that they can't actually accept what's
real and by the way i don't think
and i made this argument in my book i
don't think you can disconnect that
from having something to do with belief
i i it's such a strange place
for me to be arguing from but i really
do believe that that
conservatives generally speaking and not
all conservatives are believers
obviously
but believing in something it doesn't
mean we all have to believe
in the exact same god it doesn't mean we
all have to
have the exact same traditions but
believing in something helps
keep people sane in the storm it keeps
the ship afloat
when you're in an endless wade of
[ __ ] and that's what we're in right
now so liberals
are all kind of going nuts the and i
mean that and in this case i mean that
when i say liberals and not lefties
because there really aren't any liberals
left despite being the guy that wrote
the book defending liberalism right
um they're all sort of going nuts
because
things are obviously far worse
politically and i would say culturally
now than under trump like that's just
obvious
if you care about any sort of liberal
principle that's just deeply obvious
and yet people are now not saying
anything right
the liberals really are doing nothing in
the face of this because they don't want
to be called scary conservatives
and what i find consistently is that
conservatives are open they're decent
they're willing to talk
all that stuff that you all well know um
so it does not surprise me that over
half of white liberal women
the women these people who
self-flagellate right these people
who there was this incredible video that
went around of some school
zoom thing where a white teacher tells
people
she will no longer teach spanish because
she as a white woman
shouldn't be teaching spanish it's it's
becoming a mental disorder locism is a
mental disorder and it has
infected a huge amount of people and if
you are liberal if you are a true
liberal and you're watching this show i
hate to tell you
but you're a scary conservative now
but they'll be nice they're actually
nice